Jeff D'Andria: And then the second idea and final idea that I want to set the table for Bye.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay, this is, like, that top third view.
Jeff D'Andria: is the human element, and this is something that actually, in a big way, came from our conversation with Ashby, the applicant tracking system folks.
Jeff D'Andria: just with what's happening with a… with the num… like, the volume of applications, super interesting note, like you said, because there's so many remote positions, like, that's affecting how many applicants. People are now able to apply. You don't have to be in San Francisco, you could be…
Jeff D'Andria: In many places in the world, and definitely different states. So the amount of applications coming in are so many,
Jeff D'Andria: And what are things that are gonna be, like, the tiebreaker, when you just have tons of really qualified candidates, and then also just people using AI too much, so the resumes are starting to…
Jeff D'Andria: be less, like, too similar, and starting to have the AI voice,
Jeff D'Andria: the human element's becoming big. And so, the second thing that we'll work on today is how do we get the human element onto your resume? The term…
Jeff D'Andria: The term I like to use is, like, adding after you… you've… you've… 99% done the resume in a very… for the software engineers in the room, for instance, in a very tech… like, I've squeezed all the lemon juice out of the lemon, this is the best about me as a software engineer.
Jeff D'Andria: And then, with that, like, 1%, what's something about you, that just may not be computer science related, just something from your life, something that you love to do?
Jeff D'Andria: and adding a little human element like that.
Jeff D'Andria: when you got 5 candidates and everyone looks great, what's the tiebreaker gonna be? And I think getting a human element on there is important. We'll make that tangible in a second.
Jeff D'Andria: a quick… a quick anecdote of when I've seen this work.
Jeff D'Andria: a client of mine got a PM job at Amazon, he had been laid off from Facebook, job searching for a year, not getting many hits, and I said, we gotta… let's just try this. Let's just try to add this human element.
Jeff D'Andria: to your resume. For this person, it's like, what do you love to do, man? Like…
Jeff D'Andria: This person happens to be into, like, F1 racing, so, like, the racing… car race stuff.
Jeff D'Andria: And they're, like, a marshal, aka the person that goes on the track and volunteers to, like, pick up the debris on the track, and he'll, like, volunteer to, like, fly to different races to do that.
Jeff D'Andria: for free.
Jeff D'Andria: We added that to the resume, and…
Jeff D'Andria: ended up getting the job at Amazon, and when they reached out to say, hey, like, update, got it? I was like… and they're like, by the way, in my recruiter screen, on the… the first thing they asked me about was the F1 thing. So, it…
Jeff D'Andria: you know, it shows… and I have other examples of, like, this, but this is the time where I'm gonna say, an adjustment to try, adding the human element.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay?
Jeff D'Andria: So the two concepts I wanted to get, to set the table with you on were using the top third.
Jeff D'Andria: Top third of the resume, emphasis on that, and then adding the human element.